i like math
i like modeling
i like computers
but what i want to do is be able to use
it to help people and so it's really
interesting or kind of exciting that we
can use these tools
and helping in this humanitarian cause
[Music]
although the food bank of central and
eastern north carolina is the largest in
the state they still can't reach
everyone
i don't think people realize the
magnitude of food insecurity
we believe there are about 680 000
people that are food insecure at some
point
during the month
we can't get enough food in to solve the
problem
enter dr ivey and dr davis
they're engineers who realized analytics
could revolutionize how food banks
operate they reached out to see how they
could help
the food bank gave us tons of data
and you know initially we're like data
data data but data can be like a
blessing and a curse
they mined through millions of records
and translated the numbers into useful
information
some of the models that we have
developed try to predict the amount of
food that might be donated
the other type of models also try to
estimate how many people might be in
need of food
we try to pull in
data about unemployment
poverty to see if we can get a better
estimate of the true need in the
counties that they serve
that information gives the food bank an
efficient way to predict changes in
supply and demand
so they can reduce food waste while
maximizing the number of people they can
reach
what they have done is given us why we
should do certain things and how we
should do them but instead of saying
well that just feels right we're able to
say well the data tells us it's pretty
cool stuff
[Music]
we're making an impact
and we have the potential to do so much
more
the work we do is easily applicable to
other food banks and i think that we'll
be able to figure out how to
you know reduce the number of families
who have hunger needs
[Music]
you